this is a market solution ultimately to
one of the biggest health crises that we
have ever seen in the history of the
world
hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for reason TV
we are here with Aaron Bieber he is the
director of a billion lives which is a
documentary that examines the rise of
electronic cigarettes and what he says
is the campaign of misinformation
against them from public health agencies
and regulatory agencies it's about one
of the biggest public health
interventions potentially of all time if
you look at a cigarette growing evidence
that this is good this could be the
breakthrough that we're waiting for a
billion people could die in the 21st
century if these things take off
potentially hundreds of millions of
lives could be saved it's in theaters
now Aaron thank you very much for
talking to us you bet that'll be here
whenever you touch the topic of
cigarettes or tobacco or nicotine people
get suspicious and then I think who are
you working for
are you a shell right so what is the
nature of the funding of this movie did
you get funding from vaping companies
tobacco companies it's a studio funded
film we take no money from any outside
organizations which gave us the freedom
to kind of do what we wanted you know
and with a film called the billion lives
talking about a billion people dying
from cigarettes yeah we definitely did
not get any funding from the guys over
at the tobacco companies or the vaping
company yeah yeah certainly any or any
outside organizations whatsoever the
people that are in your film most of
them are not affiliated with a vaping
company a lot of them were on the front
lines of the anti tobacco battle could
you just kind of you know rattle off a
few of the names in your movie probably
the best example is dr. Derek yak who is
the former executive director at the
World Health Organization who is in
charge of coming up with all the rules
against smoking he thinks this is
outrageous dr. diehl on human former
president of the World Medical
Association two top doctors in the world
pretty much in the movie along with a
lot of other people that they spend
their entire careers fighting smoking
the billion life statistic is from the
World Health Organization which projects
over the next century a billion people
dying early from smoking cigarettes
right how do you see East cigarettes
reversing that trend
when I talk to these people that have
quit smoking in are now vaping they said
they feel better it tastes better it's
just it's cheaper this is a market
solution ultimately to one of the
biggest health crises that we have ever
seen in the history of the world the
reason why I think this would be so
successful is because it's working you
know it's already been successful I've
met thousands of people that have quit
it something like 40 million people
right now are using vapor technology and
almost the entire developed world anyone
who got hooked on cigarettes and having
a hard time quitting can ultimately
switch to something that's you know the
Royal College of Physicians it is at
least 95 percent safer the official ways
to quit smoking or by doing the gum or
the patch or maybe hypnotherapy or
something like that why not just limited
to these things that have actually gone
through testing the success rate it's
only like one or two percent you know
and so when I find out you know there's
a billion people smoking right now
seventy percent want to quit that's the
that's the stats but only one to two
percent of smokers are able to quit with
that I mean it's just that's not it's a
non-starter
it's not working you know it's
disturbing to me that one's something
that is working is being demonized you
know you got to start digging deeper and
that's basically what we did in a
billion lives one of the big public
health campaigns here is called still
blowing smoke they want to draw that
connection between the big tobacco
companies and vaping and say that it's
all a smokescreen pun intended I guess
so what is your reaction to that
campaign yeah well I mean it's straight
up propaganda I mean just look at the
name of it still blank smoke no people
using vapor technologies are not blowing
any smoke right away right off just the
name of it is lying to the public and
you watch these ads and we included them
in the movie so that people could see
what kind of propaganda is being put out
these guys use seventy five million
dollars of taxpayer money to run ads
even during the Olympics primetime ads
lying to people telling people that
their neighbors who are trying to quit
smoking are still blowing smoke and that
this is some ploy by big tobacco to get
the next generation hooked on on
cigarettes that's all of that is lies so
you don't buy the gateway argument it's
ridiculous
no smoking for children in the u.s. is
at all-time low and it is dropping like
this never before has it been dropping
so quickly
yet they say this is a gateway vaping is
being tried by more and more young
people instead of smoking that's
something we should celebrate but if it
was true that it was a gateway as more
people were trying vaping more people
would be smoking
that's how it works you made a point in
the film that it seems like a very basic
point but it seems to be one that people
don't understand which is that nicotine
in isolation is not proven to
necessarily be harmful but doctors even
don't seem to understand this what well
a lot of misinformation about that it's
not even true that people don't know
they know exactly all about nicotine
because we've been using patches and gum
nicotine patches and gum for many many
years and these things are been
researched and researched and researched
and they got FDA approval even for it so
this is not like we don't know what's
nicotine belief is it nicotine is it not
harmful a lot of things are harmful
waters harmful I mean you can drown from
it you can drink too much of it and have
your stomach break I mean a lot of bad
things can happen from water so nothing
really is safe but I will say this I
mean if people are drinking coffee out
there that nicotine and caffeine are
very similar very similar chemicals very
similar they both come from plants
they're both stimulants and they both
can be addictive that's for sure but
nicotine patches and nicotine gum are
not something that you see a lot of
people just addicted to on their own
kids don't try nicotine gum and then get
hooked on it it's not as addictive as
you'd think the main thing that's
addictive in cigarettes is actually some
of the other things that are in there
you know they have 4,000 plus chemicals
in these cigarettes and a lot of those
things add to that whole situation the
big study knocking each cigarettes comes
from the New England Journal of Medicine
and it says that e-cigarettes put out
formaldehyde when they're heated at high
levels why don't you accept that as a
red flag that we should be concerned
yeah that's a totally ridiculous
Rhuddlan study that was done and what
they did is they put the stuff on too
high of a temperature and it did create
formaldehyde but that's not how people
use these devices so making a study
showing how bad something is but not
actually running the study how people
would use it is of course fraudulent you
would have to heat it to such a large
degree that a human being would
be able to inhale it for a extent of the
users of these products so I mean that
this is this thing called dry puff where
it gets so hot it basically burns it
tastes terrible they would never do it
because it it's just literally would be
punishing to do it so you know in this
study said that people would be doing
this multiple times a minute for seventy
five years straight and of course that's
worse than smoking because that's just
unreasonable and yeah not how people use
it the FDA has issued new guidelines to
regulate e-cigarettes and the vapors are
not happy why not yeah well I mean
they're not happy because they don't
feel like the FDA listened and they
didn't listen ultimately you got to see
there's some sort of an agenda going on
there you'll find out that the head of
the FDA's tobacco division is actually a
former lobbyist for the people that make
nicorette gum in the US like come on we
do what they like about the regulation
well they said that it's going to close
down I mean the FDA themselves said
about 99% of the products on the market
will be put out of business by these
regulations I mean this is the FDA
saying this so if you're one of the
small businesses or the individuals or
solopreneurs that decide to kind of help
people quit smoking you want to have a
business from it this is devastating
because you no longer have a business if
we grant your points that e-cigarettes
are clearly safer than regular
cigarettes which I am very inclined to
grant that in the world pretty much
agrees that all scientists agree on that
what about the more subtle objection
from the CDC and some of these other
organizations that they're basically
invoking the precautionary principle we
might know that cigarettes are more
harmful than you cigarettes but we don't
know what the harms of e-cigarettes are
on a long-term basis
it's absolutely malpractice I mean if
you're a medical person and there's
something you know is terrible I mean
we've seen cancer and a lot of other
devastating diseases that if something
happened you know like chemotherapy that
hurts people I know people that have
died from chemotherapy but we still give
it to patients because it's better than
dying from cancer okay
in this case they know it's better than
smoking they know this everyone would
agree but you want to wait and see you
want to wait and see when harm can be
reduced a billion people are dying this
century from it but we want to wait and
see how many years we want to wait and
see
that's ridiculous what do you think
would be the best way for public health
agencies and regulators to proceed from
this point and then what do you think is
actually going to happen given your read
of the situation I was a regulatory
agency I would use the precautionary
principle on myself saying I need to be
careful before doing anything that could
hurt people and banning a product that
people are using to quit smoking is
harming people because if you can't have
an alternative and you can't quit you're
gonna keep smoking so I would say we
need to wait and see
before banning it what's ultimately
happening is the 99% of these products
will be banned in the next year or so
and you think there's any hope of
overcoming that and what might that look
like
well I think there is hope I really do
believe that but ultimately we need the
public you know to wake up to what's
happening because people are dying
because of some very interesting
entrenched relationships and funding
sources and people are dying from that
you can't sit there and watch bad things
happen you have to get involved before
there's no one left you know before you
know ultimately the big these big
organizations are just running all over
everybody we got a fight now the film is
a billion lives go to a billion lives
dot-com to find out how to get tickets
Aaron Bieber thank you very much for
talking about that Amir for reason TV
I'm Zach Weissmuller
[Music]